all right hello everybody this is
grandmaster steven zerk
this is going to be my first lecture as
gm ed resident
for the saint louis chess club so today
i want to talk about
is a series of pawn end games where the
king
or the king basically will say has some
fancy feet we're going to see
a lot of kings doing a lot of careful
maneuvering in today's puzzles
so this first one this is a study by
reddy which
some of you may have seen before
it's quite famous and it's a great i
think i'd say it's a great introduction
to our theme
and we're going to kind of develop on as
we go so
yeah again hello everybody so i'll be
monitoring the chat
so if you think you have the solution
or if you have any questions then don't
be shy
yeah so for this first position right
it's king and pawn against king and pawn
and even though our pawn is more
advanced
it looks very grim because
we can't promote our pawn right
and at the same time we're nowhere near
in time
to stop black spawn
so the outlook isn't great here
right same thing if we just try and if
we try and head straight for our pawn
then same thing king is too close our
king is too far
really the big problem here
is that our king is very badly
positioned
and so sure enough the solution here
and again this is going to occur
throughout the problems today
is to make a double threat right like a
lot of tactics
you want to make two threats at once we
don't just try to stop this pawn
because we can't we don't just try to
promote our pawn because we can't
but if you can make both of these
threats at once
then black can only respond to one right
black can't push his pawn and take our
pawn
so the solution to this first puzzle is
to combine the ideas king g7
all right at first it probably if you
haven't seen this before this probably
looks pointless
all right black goes h4 king f6
and this is the point you continue on
this diagonal
because now let's say black just says
okay well i'm going to promote my pawn
suddenly our king's no longer on h8
we've gotten to f6
which isn't just closer to the h pawn
it's closer to our own pawn
and now white just goes king e6
and after h2 c7 black can k
play king b7 but it doesn't help black
promotes and white promotes and we have
our draw
so suddenly it turns out that by going
to f6
instead of going to h6 we're actually
making just as many threats against this
pawn
and we're making just as many threats to
support our own pawn
so actually when we play king f6 black
needs to go king b6 if he doesn't want
white to promote
and i see a couple of you have the
solution very good
and here's the key this is where again
it might seem like white's in serious
trouble
because if we try to promote our pawn
we're too slow
if we try to stop black spawn or too
slow
but this is i would say the final really
nice move of the ready study
you go king e5
and there we are so this simple move
makes two threats
we're threatening to go to d6 which
promotes our pawn
and we're threatening to go to f4 which
would win black's pawn
black can easily stop either of these
threats
but it's simply impossible to stop both
yeah king e5 is a very nice move
because the funny thing one thing it's
really showcasing is the diagonal power
of the king
right the king the king on e5 is
actually doing just as good a job
fighting this h-pawn as the king on h5
and the king on e5 is doing just as good
a job helping this pawn as the king on
e8
so the king right the king can kind of
cover extra territory if you go
diagonally
it's going towards the c pawn and
towards the h-bomb even if it doesn't
look like it
right if black takes we have our draw we
win the h
pawn
if black goes h3 to promote we're no
longer in the square we can't get in the
square
but now we're close enough to our cpan
and once again we both promote at the
same time
and there's the draw
so yeah this ready study say it's a good
one to know it's a
an excellent example of using the king
well especially in the end game
because this position would be easy
would be easy it would be easy to think
it was hopeless
if you weren't aware of this idea and a
few years after his first study
ready made a second one so we'll get to
in a second so
he asked what's the general idea behind
figuring this out like practically do we
need to calculate this the whole way
through
i would say if you're talking about
solving this position
it's pretty it's clear pretty quickly
right that standard idea is c7 doesn't
work
king h7 to chase this pawn doesn't work
and so the idea
that what you really need to know is
this idea that a king on e5
is just as good for this pawn as a king
on h5
right if you go to e5 you're doing just
as well fighting the h-bomb because the
square
the square of this pawn extends all the
way over here
so i would say it's you take that
knowledge
so that lets you know that okay if
something's going to work here
it's this double threat idea is both the
single threats are inadequate
if you combine them though right black
can't handle both and then after that
comes the calculation
right king g7 is clearly the best try we
don't know you don't know before you
calculate it
works but you know it's worth looking at
and then you can check right if black
goes king b6
if black plays this order right the
order actually doesn't change anything
after king f6
you're already threatening to win this
pawn so now h4 if black wants to try to
win h4 is forced
and here right here's where you have to
have the big insight you need to get
towards this pawn and towards this bun
and king e5 is the only way to do it and
from here right you need to just check
those two lines i showed
you need to confirm that king d6
promotes and king f4 stops the pawn and
black can't do anything about these two
combined threats
so a few a few years later ready made
another study with a similar theme that
i'm going to show quickly
i made this position right here and you
can kind of see the same idea this pawn
on c6
still can't promote you know black's not
about to promote yet
but if black wins this pawn
then this is completely hopeless right
this king in three pawns against king
endgame is completely lost so what
let's just approach this position what
does white need to do here
this is another way to play and draw
what would white need to accomplish here
in order to draw
right the first thought might be to
promote this pawn or to support this
pawn
but it's just much too slow right you
can easily check
if we try and help our pawn we're
actually two moves too slow
and this is hopeless
so what can we do here
right very good so this time
we go king g6 but after king b6
we can't support our pawn but sure
enough yeah actually
this becomes a very similar we can't
support our pawn our only hope
is to try and decimate these pawns and
you take
king takes g7
so first of all if black decides to deal
with our c pawn
then we take we can we take the f pawn
and this h-bond is gone and we have our
draw
the other hand let's say black goes f5
all right we actually we have a very
similar situation to the ready study
all right we can't stop this pawn we
can't promote this pawn
but we make the exact same double threat
king f6
and king e5
there we go this probably looks very
familiar after the first position
black can grab this pawn or black can
promote this pawn
but he only gets one move he cannot do
both
so once again black can get queen and
pawn against queen
that is the one perk he has compared to
the first end game
but this position is a pretty easy draw
queen and rook pawn against queen
is usually a draw and doubly so when
your own king is closer to the rook pawn
than the opponent's king
so yeah actually you make the exact same
thread against the f pawn
and funnily enough if black plays h5
you take on f6 and by now this position
should look very familiar
you literally transpose to the ready
study h4
and king e5 again
and it is like i said literally the
exact same takes king f4
and we are all set
and right yeah so in queen and pawn
against queen i mentioned king on each
one
almost guarantees a draw on that end
game yeah that is correct right if this
king gets here
because every queen trade is a draw
white can basically just sit
and there's not much black can do if you
want to try and win a position like this
as black your king really needs to be
supporting the pawn and using the queen
and pawn for defense against checks
this position as long as you don't let
the queens trade when your king is
outside the square
should be a pretty easy draw for white
all right we're going to look at some
more examples that build on this theme
so this next position this is a trickier
version
so we have a king and pawn against king
and pawn again
we have the same problem right our king
is not in the square of this pawn
so our king can't stop the h pawn
our pawn is black's king isn't a square
of r pawn
so if we try and promote we have no luck
so our only hope here is actually to
create a similar double threat right
both of our
individual threats can easily be handled
by black
so to draw this position we need to find
some creative way to combine them
now one nice thing about pawn end games
here there's only three legal moves and
one of them draws
what could we do how can we try
and combine
promoting threats with threats of
promoting our apon
with improving our king to stop black's
each bomb
so that's so that's the right idea but
there's a problem right if we go king c8
king c6
a6 king here king b8
and this is the right idea right you're
threatening to promote so black has to
take
and now you can go to c7 the only
problem is c7 is not good enough right
black gets to go two squares
so we actually cannot get in the square
that is the right idea though can we
find a slightly better way
to use thread of promoting this a5 pawn
right he has h5 h if it weren't for h5
that would work perfectly
but remember upon the second rank is a
little harder to catch than it looks
so the key this time is we actually
we want to make this double threat with
our king on this rank
all right a6 and king e7 doesn't work
because
we're not making a double threat we're
making one threat to getting the square
and black can handle that easily
so is there a way we could maybe move
our king to the second rank
to the seventh rank i should say and
threaten to promote our pawn at the same
time
right chess king's got it so
you don't push the pawn yet
right so king c8
we're threatening to promote right h5
would be a big mistake from black
a6 and c6 a7 and suddenly black's lost
forget the draw
so king b8 right and chess king
mentioned king b8 there's no king b6
this is important
we're threatening to promote again so
black has to go king b5
and now yep as you mentioned king b7
is the key move we improve our king
funnily enough since the right since the
king moves diagonally
this king is actually better off than
the one on d8 even if it might not look
at it
it might not look it
we're threatening to promote one last
time so black finally gets our pawn
but we've gotten to the we've gotten to
b7 with tempo we can play king c6
and h5 no longer does the draw no longer
does the job for black
and we have our draw
all right very good so this next one
this one's from a real game
yates marshall
and in this position black has two
choices
so here black can either check with the
bishop
king g6
trade these bishops and take b3
so this would give black a pawn up
bishop end game
or black can trade all the bishops
and try to promote a pawn
so in the game black decided to go for
the pawn in game
and as you might might have guessed
already
this is a mistake so black's thinking
was this
black wanted to play h black wanted
after h4 king g4
was thinking that when white went for
this pawn
can trade king e5
and how would black win this position
what was black's thinking here
all right if we take white mops up these
pawns and if anything we're going to
lose
yeah so c3 right this is a nice
this is a nice tactic takes
a4 king d4 right and a3
and tragically white's own pawn dooms
him
so this was black's idea right the king
can't catch up
game over
but what was the disappointment here
right what did black miss in this
position
what nasty surprise did gates did
for marshall right
same actually very similar to the last
puzzle king g6
another double purpose move
so we're threatening h5 black certainly
does not want to allow this
so black abs black has to take this but
in addition to threatening h5
we've improved our king and this time
when we play
king f5 we're not on f6 or on f5
and after c4 takes takes we don't go to
e5
which would lose to the same tactic but
to e4
and this time c3 takes a4
we don't go to d4 we go just
we go to d3 and if black gets if black
tries to push this pawn even loses
yeah so this once again
this dual purpose king move saves the
day
so in retrospect black actually so black
miscalculated the pawn end game instead
the game was a draw but black should
have gone for the bishop end game check
hear take stakes and take here
and this this bishop end game is
actually a pretty easy one
all right the bishop worst case it's
going to sacrifice itself for the h pawn
and the king and three will overwhelm
the bishop in one
all right yeah good solving so the next
few positions i'm going to show
are some puzzles from upon a game
composer
and these ones i mean he has many great
pawning games with many themes
these ones are again going to build on
this kind of flexible
multi-purpose king that we're seeing in
the ready studies in this game
in this position
how to do it though this position once
again we can't promote our b-pawn we
can't stop black's h-bomb
so it's clear from what we've discussed
that we need to make this double threat
but how do we do it that's actually a
tricky question to answer here
if you go king a4 you're not getting any
closer to the pawn
if you go king b3 you're not supporting
your b-pawn
so what do we do here how do we do a
move
that both supports our b-pawn which is
not a threat at the moment
and chases the h-bomb which is out of
range
at the moment
yeah so also b5 is an idea to make
threats with this pawn
the problem is black's king is
comfortably in the square
right so black could even
let's see what would be the well i mean
black's still in range to stop the pawn
so black could also push could push the
h-bomb
but simplest would actually just be to
move the king over
and when we play king b4 we're
threatening to catch this pawn
if we get another move but black plays
h5
king c5
ah sorry i stand corrected this would
act so this would actually work this
would be
under from black because now we're
making a double threat
here we're threatening to stop the pawn
or here we actually promote
oh sorry i just evaluated that
so that was a good attempt actually b5
king b4 c5
that's the right idea but as you're
seeing it's just a bit too slow
so but let me ask you is there another
way you can kind of bring the king up
can you bring the king closer to
supporting this pawn
and closer to catching this pawn
i've got mention of king a4 a couple
mentions of king b3
so the problem is king b3 doesn't really
support your b-pawn
h5 can hear h4
and you're not you're not going well and
here
you're just not in time to do anything
with your b pawn
b5 h3 b6
and black just walks up your b-pawn
needs your king's help
to promote but here it's just too slow
yeah this is a tricky one a lot of these
end games are
all right now we're getting on the idea
so king a4 so let's ask ourselves first
of all king a4
if black just pushes the h pawn
now we still can't quite promote
because after b5 king d7 if we just try
and promote the pawn like this the king
sits in front
but instead of that the key here the
real key here is to promote our pawn
it needs the support of the king on a7
alright if black's king gets to b8 we're
never promoting
so we need to get our king to a7 to
prevent this
so the key here is actually king a5
all right we don't want to block our own
pawn here in this case
but now after h4 b5
and the key is just that if black's king
tries to stop us
we're just we just have to be ready to
go to a7 right we can't let him get to
b8 we can't let him sit in front of our
pawn
h3 b6
and now our king is in time to help our
pawn
so that would be that would give us our
draw
but okay hang on what if black says
after king a4
you're not any closer to the h pawn
right so you still can't catch the h
pawn
so instead of pushing it i'm going to
move my king closer i'm going to play
king d7
this is the real question after king a4
king d7
we're still not in the square we're
still not promoting
what do we do
all right black's king can get to b8
this pawn is still not
we're still not in the square of the
pawn
so any one threat is not good enough
here
right chest king is on fire today
so mentioned king b5
and this is it so first of all now we
are closer to the h-bomb
so if black goes king c7 okay we can't
promote
but we don't need to anymore now this
one thread is enough we go king c5
and king d5 and there we are we're in
the square
so king b5 threatens to stop the h pawn
we're now close enough that black has to
play h5 if he doesn't if he wants to
promote his pawn but now what what's the
other perk of moving the king to b5
all right we can't stop the h5 pawn what
can we do
all right king c5 is no good anymore
right
yeah but this time correct adam
we go to a6 so even though we we took we
took a little
pit stop in front of the pawn now we
step out of the way
and this time black will never get to b8
all right if black pushes the pawn we're
just in time
this time if black tries to stop us if
black tries to get his king to b8 we go
here
and once again black can't stop the
promotion
there's a neat little trick that black
can use here you might have seen this
before but after king c6
we go king a6 king c7 we don't want to
allow x king to the b file we go king a7
and this little repetition i believe is
called a windmill
and it actually leads to the to a draw
there's no way for black to stop this
b-bomb anymore all he can do is force
this repetition
we don't let him go to the b file and we
have our draw
yeah so this is a very nice example
because the surprising move king b5
comes up a couple moves in which makes a
double threat of king a6 to promote
and king c5 to stop the h-bomb
all right let's see another example
now this next one this next one is very
sneaky actually
this one's a favorite of mine so you
probably already noticed the
similarities to the ready study
which might give you a hint first of all
let's try the direct plan
what if we just try to promote our f
pawn well we take g3
f6 and we'd have drawing chances if this
pawn were here
unfortunately it is not
so this is one move too slow black
promotes with check we'll never play f7
even if we get rid of this c pawn this
will never work
a pawn on the seventh rank on this on a
f7 or c7 draws against a queen
but f6 is not good enough so we can't go
the director out
we also can't promote this pawn right
once again black's king is closer than
ours
but what can we do kind of sticking to
the ready theme what might be
an idea we can try
alright so king f6 king f6 is a move
and if if black plays g3 first of all if
black goes to promote
we can go king e6 king e7 also works
but king e6 both sides promote and we
have our draw
so actually after king f6 if black wants
to try and win
they have to go king b6
so we're not in time to save our pawn we
still can't take on g6 it loses just
like before
but king f6 king b6 what can we do here
that we can't promote we can't take this
but this is this puzzle actually
involves a couple clever tricks
to save the game now we go king e5
right we're threatening to promote this
is exactly like the ready study we're
threatening promote
we're threatening to get in the square
so black again if black wants to try and
win they have to take the pawn
if both sides promote it's an easy draw
for white
and now we have achieved one thing right
black's gotten our pawn but now we're in
the square
of black spawn king d4
that being said this this study this
puzzle is still not over right
are we sure this is a draw
and this is a bit separate but it's such
an elegant finish that's
i can't help but show it so here
right black can't promote
but this time let me show you
black can't promote but what if he tries
for this
if we're careless let's say we do let's
say we just try to keep the king here
this is lost because black brings his
king to f5
g3 and g2 right we have to take this
pawn it's a successful diversion
black takes and this king and pawn
against king is lost
the king is on a key square
here though this part is one of my
favorite tricks
right we can't just stall if black's
king comes to f5 and black pushes the g
pawn black wins
however white's got a trick up his
sleeve
king e3 king d5
king f2 king e4
king g3 so black gets to f5 again
but now we surprise him with this king
h4
and funnily enough this position is
usually zip zone
all right usually white doesn't want to
move here
but suddenly we go king h4 yeah and
black has no move he either gives up a
pawn black either gives up a pawn
or black takes on f4 with stalemate
yeah so that's basically a two-part
study first you have to see the ready
idea to get in the square
and then to draw this king and pawn
against king and two pawns
you need to see this stale matrix
yeah and funnily enough one of my
favorite parts is the route white skin
takes in this study
just a long diagonal walk to h4
all right next up
yeah a lot of these puzzles a lot of
these in our puzzles
they have a lot of clever ideas behind
them and it's even with just a few
pieces right
the reddy studies with king and pond
against king and pawn you can find a
surprising number of ideas
in this next one in this next one this
one's actually white to play and win
so for the first time
yeah for the first time in the session
we're trying to win a position
now first of all if we want to try and
win
we need to keep these pawns if we go
king e5
among other things black can take king
f6 king g8
and here right you're not promoting once
this king is in front you're never
promoting the pawn yep so as you guys
are saying g6 is absolutely forced
and hang on so now
after a4
so black plays a4 right black wants to
promote their own pawn
and this this is where white needs to be
clever what should white try here
i guess i'll ask it this way how do you
typically promote these pawns
because for the moment they're stopped
what's the typical idea to promote one
of these pawns
if for example black didn't have any
pawns of their own
right so king e5 is the direct route
so after king e5
a3 king takes e6 this is how you
typically win in this end game
the king comes to e6 you promote the
h-pawn
black takes and your king walks up
but there's a problem here you might be
seeing it already after a2
promote king takes king f7
promote and we have a big problem
this queen is covering g7
but this is no good if we could only
promote we would actually be winning
you'd have check jqueen and queen g6
mate
but we need to be we need to be a bit
cleverer than this
if we want to win this position
right any ideas here what else can we do
and if you remember how strong if we can
keep if we can use the king more
flexibly
yeah first gobble up a pawn so that
would be great right if we could just
take this a pawn
we would be winning the problem is these
pawns are too advanced if we just go for
the a pawn
hang on can we do that e4 takes e3
uh-oh we're not catching that pawn
so yeah if that would be a great
strategy if we could pull it off just
win one of these pawns
that would be an easy win
so we can't just go promote our pawn
we can't just win one of the black pawns
but actually by combining the ideas
white has a very clever one here
this is another great study
all right someone in chat is spotting
the idea if black plays e5
suddenly this queen would be interrupted
all right good catch yes see it you go
king c4
right you're targeting this pawn so if
black just sits
now you can go king b4 and this pawn is
free so when you play king c4
e5 is forced from black
and now you go to d5
and this is the point we want black to
keep this pawn
after a3 now you go king e6
and you get the same position with one
difference black has an extra pawn
and thanks to his e5 pawn black gets
checkmated e2
or a2 sorry white queens
takes king f7 and queen
exact same position with an extra pawn
for black
and thanks to that e5 pawn check right
no coverage
promote and this classic checkmate
now so this king c4 king d5 maneuver is
key
very clever from white what if e4
so what if e4 at what point
do you mean so e5 king d5 e4
so you do the same thing this time black
is too slow king e6
e3 promote
what if e4 instead of a4
well so e4 is not legal here
if you play e5 instead of a4 white's
white's in the square now it takes
so if you play e4
right if you play e4 at
sorry if you play e4 at this point
it's just too late white wins the same
way king e6 e3
queen and black doesn't even get the
queen
e2 and we have the same checkmate
so once again some great flexibility
with some great flexibility with the
king
to induce e5 which is exactly where
black does not want the pawn
black would be fine with the spawn
anywhere else but here it blocks the
queen
all right nicely spotted alright let's
see
next one
all right this one so this one is pretty
advanced
we're going to talk about how we would
approach this position
so first of all in this position
if black gets to coordinate his king and
start advancing this is just lost
these kind of two on ones if for example
let's say you just bring the king up
black checks king e5 king e7
these kinds of end games are basically
always lost
king back king here and the simplest way
is just to move the king up
and now if you try to hold on to this
pawn black just uses this e pawn for a
diversion
and you can't handle both threats
so in this position white needs to do
something quick
white needs to make a very fast threat
what can white do here to cause quick
immediate problems for black before
black can consolidate
and fix their poor king position
right moving the king up towards d5 is
not enough
just advancing the king is not enough
right so king c4 this is the key
and your idea is pretty simple it's to
go after the b-pawn
and if for example black black's not in
time to defend this pawn
if you just win it this is an easy draw
right e5 king c5
you're in the square now white has no
problems at all
so black can't just let you have the
b-pawn
so king c4 is key
and now let's say black goes king e8 and
after king b5 says okay well while
you're taking that pawn
i'm going to go e5 and if you take i
promote
so this e5 is the real danger
now if we take black pushes you check
the pawn race
but here black's king is too close to
our pawn
king comes up we tried it we try to
support the pawn between before check
and this is hopeless
so suddenly e5 we don't have time to
take the pawn
but this is where a very nice solution
comes in for light
right we just go back the way we came
king c4
and suddenly it turns out e5 has done
quite a favor
it's given y to target
right black must defend this pawn again
if white wins this pawn it's an easy
draw
so the only try for black is king here
king d5 and king f6
and now it might seem like things have
gotten worse
but as it turns out since black's king
has been pulled back to the f phone
we have an idea here right we can't win
the e pawn anymore
we want to play king c6
but then black starts pushing the pawn
if we go king e4
these end games are lost right this two
on one
is always bad for white we need counter
play
we can't just defend our way to a draw
here down upon like this
it worked only at a stale matrix right
once again correct answer c4 the key
here is
we can't stop this pawn that's going to
lose we have to go for counter play
but if we go for counter play now if we
go for it now
our pawn is too slow we're only on c6
the c7 pawn is a draw but c6 is not good
enough
the pawn on the seventh right c7 f7 pawn
draw against the queen but as a couple
of you mentioned
correctly black's not threatening e4 yet
so we play c4 first
it's an important tempo
and after king f5
now we go king c6 e4
takes and right it's a similar position
but we've gotten to play c4 and black's
played king f5
c4 is great for us king f5 not so much
for black
so now after e3 instead of getting to c6
black promotes and we go to c7
and this endgame right as your in-game
book should tell you
with the king on the f file like this
right not on e8 like it was in the bad
variation
we've pulled the king to the f file and
now this end game is a draw
because of this well-known trick or
because of the well-known stale matrix
i won't showcase that now
yeah nice catch so yeah the big one here
is the king's flexibility
you have to make quick threats otherwise
this end game is bad
so you have to go to b5 black's only try
because you're threatening to just
get an easy draw is e5 and this is where
you need flexibility
taking on b6 now is hopeless
all right black's king is going to be
too close to our c pawn we're not going
to promote
so you need this flexibility with king
c4
it doesn't win the e pawn all it does in
fact
is it pulls black's king back to the
f-file to f6 and then f5
but with our pawn getting to c7
that is enough
all right nicely done we have one more
on a very similar theme
alright in this last one
this time our king is much better than
blacks
black's general idea is to play c4
and takes but it's not actually a threat
right away
right c4 takes b3 c5 b2 c6
queen c7 there we'd have the same draw
as before
but the question is what do we do
all right we need to make a threat if we
don't black's king will just start
marching over or marching over
so arcane needs to move up so that that
first point is correct we definitely
don't want our king on the c file if we
go to c6
this is a mistake black pushes and we
lose a valuable tempo
we have to move our king out of the way
we only get to c6
and this always loses right you need to
get to c7
so we can't go to c6 because that will
lose a tempo when we try to promote our
c pawn
and here's the problem we could try
going to d6
at first this seems like the right idea
and the idea is correct but after we do
these again
black promotes we go c7
with the king on d7 this is an easy draw
right with the king supporting the pawn
the c7 pawn draws against the queen but
here our king is on d6 instead of d7
and this actually proves to be a problem
why is the king on d6 not as good what
move does black have here
right yeah because our king is no longer
here
to cover c cover ca right we want to
cover c8 and threaten to promote
but this is the key black has queen f5
and now the difference here is there's
no way to stop queen c8
all right if white goes to e7 or to c6
doesn't change anything
black goes queen c8 white has to go back
to d6
and with the queen here on c8
there's no way for white to threaten to
promote right the king can't even
approach the queen
that's one problem of a king against a
queen and black's king has
all the time in the world to just walk
back and win the pawn
now you never want to let the queen
blockade your pawn in a situation like
this
so why not queen b8 if you mean queen b7
which is a move to look at
the difference here is queen b7 doesn't
cover d7
so now white has king d7 and black
doesn't get queen c8
and this is a draw right white plays
king d8 and his threatening promotion
if you go to f5 you cover this d7 square
and that means white can't stop queen c8
yes so once again
chess king is on fire today the key here
we don't want to allow this queen f5
so we need to threaten king d5 right we
need to make a threat
but we don't have to do it from d6
the key move is king e6
and so we're still making we're not
threatening to take right away but if we
play king d5 we're just winning these
pawns
we're actually just going to win if
black let's let's get these bonds
so c4 is still completely forced
takes we get this same pawn race
and we only get to c7
but this time with our king on e6
instead of d6 funnily enough it might
look like it's farther away from the
pawn
but the key factor is we're covering
this f5 square
and sure enough black actually has no
way to get the queen to c8
like in the lines with our king on d6
and we've actually salvaged the draw
right
this king position showed a lot of
foresight
now if queen b7 as we discussed before
king d7 reaches a draw
and there's just no way to get to the c8
square
yeah so manny that's a great question
what if queen d1
so this is a clever try from black
right if white queens that would be a
sad mistake white's gotten to queen but
black has the skewer
so instead of cleaning right king e7
and now right now black has to stop
promotion there's no more skewer tricks
but white has time for king d8 and the
promotion is covered
very good so queen d1 is a good try
right threatening the skewer but you're
not threatening to go to ca unlike queen
f5 you're not threatening queen c8
and that means white has time to solve
the skewer problem
black can also try to be tricky by going
king g4
alright this is another attempt to set
up a skewer with queen f5
white dare not promote but once again
white goes king d7
and without getting the queen to c8
black cannot win this endgame
yeah so those that was a series of fun
games just again i hope you're seeing
kind of the multi-purpose possibility
and a lot of the flexibility of the king
all right we saw it go to b5 and back to
c4 so a lot of double threats
and you see the use of this king's
ability to move diagonally
because here it turns out king e6 is
just as threatening as king d6 and e6 is
a much better square
in the future
yeah so the king has a lot of potential
in these end games
yeah good solving everybody i hope you
enjoyed the puzzles
and i hope to see you for the next
lecture which is coming up in just a
couple minutes
alright thank you everybody bye